sono tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo incredibile entusiasmante
paurosissimo episodio di omofobia che
l'orrore che sta spopolando nel mondo
speriamo che non esistono ste cose sono
siamo nella m spero che vi piaccia sono
con mai state vere e poi giro comunque
c'è di fair garcia dobbiamo parlare se
sbagli spagnolo ne parleremo in spagnolo
scopri che con tipo di fantasma io a che
fare e fino a qualche bene allora
jennifer garcia la possiamo chiamare
tutti quanti è in spagnolo ragazzi
perché sta in spagna e gross street gta
sarà 3 qualcosa il fantasma di gta vabbe
dai entriamo tipo di dato sono case è
anche bella questa casa peccato che sia
infestata cioè questa e violazione di
domicilio voglio provare a [ __ ] la
macchina un fantasma vediamo se riesco
siamo comunque siamo sempre comunque in
gta
mi sa che mi fa cagare nelle mutande ma
smettila mi sono cagato addosso non ha
idea san patrizio
comunque siamo sempre gta quindi
qualcosa possiamo rubarlo è per forza ma
che il pd strina e allora però non si
apre non si apre però non me la fa
selezionare la chiamata non me l'ha
aperta come dunque al camp nou però
qualcosa si apre per forza se no che
cacchio serve una chiave qualcosa per
forza si deve aprire jennifer garcia o
sei mia nonna o sei mio zio ma c'è man
mano ragazzi voce meno 20 gradi
c'è una pazzia eccola allora in ombra e
l'ombra di ferro in ombra difensori qua
ci sono meno 9 gradi meno 9 gradi e non
sia forse qui soggetti per garcia qua
qua fa veramente freddo raga oddio sta
impazzendo tutto sto impazzendo tutto è
vista ok ok
si fidavano arriviamo resistete
ecco un addio perché voglio sempre io no
ma cosa c'entro io
ma perché devo morì mannaggia sto gioco
maledetto ma che ma perché voglio sempre
io
non è giusto basta morire il tuo gioco
basta mi sono rotto
scusaci fare con i fantasmi io ma basta
io non ho fatto il corridoio na 6 ma
perché leo morì per primo basta basta
voi per primi questo gioco basta da
avuto basta e ci abbiamo molto in uganda
tranne due canti è infatti come problema
sì siamo morti solo in due per opposto
dai tutto ok bella giornata perfetto no
ho già trovato la torcia per sbaglio
charles davis xvi spiega che entriamo
già sponda a nozze o io termometro che
pirla ok allora 13 gradi spero non sia
in cucina come l'altra volta vediamo non
è in cucina attenzione non è in cucina
forse il piano misure a 8 gradi qua ci
sono 8 gradi sono buoni charles davis
charles davis mi hanno già ammazzato una
volta qua non mi fai paura
già è sentito mai sentito ha detto lee è
a e vi ha detto lo sentivo lega ha
risposto ha detto l'idea ma è la stessa
che palle sta ma perché inquina le prove
con l'uomo
hai detto per due ore detto sono charles
davis che sembrava il disco rotto
la cosa charles davis
io sto sul trono e tu sei miei piedi
charles davis fai schifo charles davis
non fai paura a nessuno ma a chi hai
detto troppo ho mai insultato lega ma
insultato lui stavolta nella stessa e
l'ho sentito ha detto troy
madre il primo charles davis non
risultare non ti non ti permettere non
ti permettere di nominare mia madre cosa
mai più charles davis come ti permetti
di nominarmi fai schifo
charles dei mets
non ho paura di te ti chiami ci si aiuta
a dio che jobs che ne so cagato nelle
mutande rega aiuta io mi sono calato dei
pantaloni santo gesù è mai spuntato
davanti mita razzetto ed io vi apre la
porta si apre aiuto svegliate dolce
signora qua traggano moglie che è morto
morto qualcuno
oddio chi è chi sei tu oddio hai fatto
ancora che marchierà io ma chi è morto
se stesso e morto stand
prendiamo la camera che fanno i video va
bene rimango io rimango io rimango io ho
sta parlando sta mettendo robe sul
quaderno sta mentendo rope sul quaderno
sta parlando ed equa se lo chiamò la
arriva subito dove si è di cello e dice
time dice cose del genere
in più il quaderno iscritto adesso la
prova a chiamarlo charles davies
sì sì stranissima rivera charles davies
a rio gere liston killer man i love you
to speech andato bene grazia come cosa
stai vago ecco ci bastavano basta vanta
dalla shimano dalla cucina andato in
fondo lascia in mano e un matto ma dove
io non ho però è in corso da rendermi
cucina adesso ma dopo una cucina arriva
cucina ecco bravi a just e res mar la
porta prima madonna che anziate era era
quarta va quasi sì sì sì sì ci stiamo ma
dalla grazia era con cucina regalare di
acam e cadute a nyon
sì sì ma faccio ripete due volte madonna
ha parlato ha scritto da franco digitale
e rimproveri impronta ciao papà la mamma
morta tutta la mano sulla faccia e beat
box
le impronte digitali e libro spiriti
così amy da amy da che uno spirito lo
spirito si sia uno spirito uno spirito
lo spirito ce la possiamo giocare a
posto abbiamo trovato ci andiamo via
alla prossima
io mi sia piaciuto ragazzi è stato
meraviglioso se ce l'ho mi piace un
sacco speriamo di non incontrare
fantasmi nella vita reale ma vediamo di
fare altre partite molto divertenti in
questi giorni voi fatemi sapere sempre i
commenti cosa ne pensate
iscriviti al canale spiacente tasto mi
piace passata anche dei canali dei
ragazzi che trovate in bad description e
noi come sempre il cd vediamo ad un
prossimo video beh ragazzi
[Musica]